but here are 10 signs
that your debt is out of control
yeah you're a little you're scared right
there i am i don't know do you want to
do a little song and dance real quick or
maybe mexican song no no nothing okay
all right so if you've got debt here's
some things you should be thinking about
here are 10 signs your debt is out of
control numero uno
well that was just more for you yeah
sorry number one you struggle to make
the minimum
payments
okay i'm not talking about that's a huge
sign yeah that's a huge sign not you
know not paying it in full every month
the minimum you can't pay the minimum
the minimum is usually 25 bucks dude
depending on what you owe 50 bucks maybe
100 bucks you can't pay the minimum stop
yeah stop bro yeah things are getting
out of control you probably know this by
now but stop you can't pay the minimum
stop using your credit cards number two
your debt grows every month the whole
point of you know paying off the debt is
so it goes down and down and then and
down but if you pay the minimum you'll
notice that let's say you owed five
thousand on a credit card you pay the
minimum next month you owe 5200 it's
like what yeah interest rates working
against you yeah that 24
no bueno
okay this is a vicious cycle it gets
very ugly out there that uh that is not
sustainable long term
some of this stuff is obvious but some
of the you know we just talked about the
average credit card in america 5 500
bucks right so maybe it's not so obvious
right
so it's like uh marcelo gave the analogy
he's like if you play golf every week
and your score is getting worse like you
shot a 90 and now then you're shooting
at 95. and then the next week you shoot
100 and then you're shooting 110 it's
like maybe you need to do things
differently yeah same thing with your
credit card if you if you owe 5000 in
the next month you owe 5200 and then a
year from now now you owe seven grand
it's like you're going the wrong way bro
yeah okay and ladies i don't want to
just say bro but
um anyway if your debt grows every month
number three
this breaks my heart to say it you're
just not saving any money nothing if all
your money is going towards your
necessities and your debt payments
focus on paying those debts and clearing
up your finances if you can't save
you're never gonna be able to get ahead
you're drowning in debt it's a vicious
cycle number four
your credit score is suffering important
not the most important but important one
of the factors that alleviate the
negatives of debt is that paying off
debt builds up your credit score cool
it's better to have a good credit score
than a bad credit score but if your
credit score is only going down down
down
you got to make a change like michael
jackson make that change
okay you reference michael jackson i
love that
i do
we won't go in the mirror the man in the
mirror make that change same song i'm
talking to the man in the mirror when it
comes to your finances they say that
you know i i'm gonna i'm gonna start
something new you know they say that
it's
that it's 20 knowledge 80 behavioral
they the experts yeah i think it's just
straight up 50 50. i'm gonna start using
that from now on 50 knowledge because
knowledge is power then 50
behavior a lot of times you got to look
in the mirror and say dude what are you
doing
enough can't go out this weekend
no more partying no more vacations no
more fiesta no more fiesta
no more
more tequila no more tequila fiesta
that's it sucks no more mexico no more
cancun
let me rein it in and save that money
so
anyway your credit score is suffering
the lower your credit score sinks the
higher your interest rates will rise
it's kind of like
lower the credit score higher the
interest yeah
adverse effect all right number five
debt collectors are calling this is the
freaking oh my first god bro that's
that's the change that should be number
one yeah that's the worst once the debt
collector start calling
things are getting dangerous for your
finances
your debt is sent to a collection agency
the odds are good that your credit
rating will down and the late fees have
been added on to what you owe all right
that's the side point yeah but the calls
the fricking calls
lose my number bro first date you're
with the girl she gets a call from a
debt collector what do you do
how much do i like this girl
you just you just met her she's got good
banter
i'm in a great body
i'm in i'm a big fan of banter
um
yeah i don't know that i well we talked
about a couple episodes ago
um oh yeah you got to know your dress
with your partner before you really you
know dive deep into a relationship or
get married no dad is one of them
the last thing you want to do is you
know start dating a girl or you know you
get married and you find out she's got
you know a mortgage she didn't tell you
about a hundred thousand dollars of
student loans no ten grand of credit
mortgages now we have that problem this
is a you problem this is not a me
problem all right number six you're
living paycheck to paycheck well i think
you know two-thirds of americans live in
paycheck to paycheck sixty percent of
millennials making a hundred grand or
more are living paycheck to paycheck and
forty percent of just americans playing
all the americans
making a hundred thousand dollars or
more or living paycheck to paycheck it's
not fun it's not pretty this is not what
you want from your life but if you're
living paycheck to paycheck this is a
sign that your debt is out of control or
you have a spending problem you don't
know how to save that money adjust your
lifestyle
when every paycheck disappears nearly as
fast as it arrives in one out and one
door out the other you can feel that
you're walking on thin ice right
any emergency in that situation is
likely to throw into throw you into more
debt that you can't afford the last
thing you want to do is we talk about
having a cushion have an emergency fund
saving that money a rainy day fund is
you know what happens from time to time
happens yeah happens it
happens bro that's why you need to have
a cushion and understand that shit's
going to happen so anytime you have an
emergency the last thing you want to do
is have to put on your credit card you
know it's a car problem it's always a
car problem for some capacity it's
always like you know everything was
going just fine and then
the radiator blew out and then the
engine had a problem and the
the check engine light went it's like
the same story it's like with every
episode i don't think by 100 episodes i
don't know if i'm going to be a
billionaire but i think i just won't
have a car yeah
100 episodes
save that money
uh number seven
you're hiding your debt let me tell you
something ignoring it won't make it go
away you remember the uh
in the road runner yeah every time that
the coyote and the roadrunner were doing
their thing and like there was a train
coming and the coyote would just like
pull down the shade because his house
was on the tracks yeah the train's
coming bro yeah the train's coming no
matter what you do with the shades um
ignoring your debt won't make it go away
so address it that's kind of the point
of this entire conversation you have
something to say on that one no i mean
what's that saying that the
things that are guaranteed in life death
and death and taxes yeah
that has nothing to do with no nothing
at all but thank you
well good plate uh all right number
eight you're losing sleep over your
finances this is probably the frickin
worst they're all bad
but when you can't even sleep against
because the collection agencies are
calling the debt collectors are calling
and it's taking a toll on your physical
health
and you're just like that's the sign
anything's out of control if you can't
sleep man of course make that change
make that change thank you mj um take
care of your health health is wealth
stress is the enemy take care of it take
care of it never a good look that's
number eight uh losing sleep over your
finances
take some nyquil traffic debt get a good
night's sleep a little ambien number
nine you have to borrow money to keep up
with living costs
uh this is something that uh you have to
borrow money just to live your normal
life
you have to get into the debt just to
pay rent
so there's something called forbearance
and there's some options out there
to lighten your debt load so you might
want to look into that number 10
your credit cards are just straight up
maxed out maxed out if you're maxing out
your credit cards number one you need to
relax yeah stop spending okay it's like
going to a buffet and just eating and
eating and eating and eating eventually
you're gonna get sick and you're
probably gonna throw up it's not gonna
be a good look for you all right you'll
be too full and just like feel horrible
so pace yourself don't be maxing out
your credit cards um
here's the deal let's wrap this up those
are the ten things that uh ten signs
that your debt is out of control here's
a little advice to you so whether you
have a little bit of debt a lot of bit
of debt no matter here's my little
advice for you
take a piece of paper write down these
three things write down the debt name
right right write down the amount
and then write down the interest rate
next to it okay
the name
the amount the interest rate how much
you owe and how much you're getting
screwed to owe that amount basically
okay
and then basically you have two options
legitimate options i'm not talking about
debt consolidation or anything like
that's a whole other topic you have two
options in order to pay off your debt
there's something called the debt
snowball and there's something called
the debt avalanche debt snowballs where
you start with the smallest debt first
bang that out boom let's say you owe
five different debts right yeah start
with the smallest 500 bucks boom you're
done move on to the next one thousand
bucks boom you're done
next thing five thousand bucks boom
you're done
move on move on and then you tackle the
big one last that's the debt snowball
it's kind of like a
like a snowball huh the opposite of that
equally as
um vital or equally as important is
something called a dead avalanche you
say look i got these five pieces of debt
one of them is zero percent one of them
is uh six percent one of them is ten
percent one of them is twelve percent
one of them is twenty five percent the
debt avalanche says start with the 25
percenter bro that is the one that is
screwing you the most get that out of
your life asap from there you go to the
next one just go to the 12 and you go to
the 10
and you work your way down to the zero
percent
either way make a plan write down the
three things that i talked about the
name of the debt the amount of the debt
the interest rate pick a path debt
snowball debt avalanche choice is yours
but get that out of your life makes
sense makes sense
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken